all right all right here we go i have no
i'll tell you right now if jake knocks
him out with it with ease it's off to
the [ __ ] races yes
oh without a doubt goddamn without a
doubt
oh man so many other fighters can come
out the woodworks trying to fight him
i'm [ __ ] nervous now i'm nervous
why is woodley so low like that hey and
when you're short it's better to be
shorter
oh you it's better to be shorter it's
harder to fight a shorter guy if you you
got to get loyal when you're shorter
wow feel them out a little bit here
here we go
wow
it's going to be different here
relax
relax t-wood more control more relaxed
yeah he's way more control than all
these others
nice slow jab there
and t-wood hits come on wood has the
white stamp yeah and he looks big
[ __ ] strong
wow big ol ass
wood got a big
yeah that's respect out of jake though
that just shows a sign of intelligence a
real different pace for sure in this
fight
and all the other ones
well thank you [ __ ] move
he looks [ __ ] good
yeah wow tyler need to double that jab
i'm still shocked at this [ __ ] belt
that he's got on his waistband oh his
waistline that's dope
yeah look there's leds on his
pants oh [ __ ] even at his hips up
nice job he's doubling up that jab man
yeah he's reaching there though that's
trouble
the reach yeah
how did boxing how did boxing getting
did get to this huh you two what with
[ __ ] leds on their belts and yeah
listen man it's always because the
boxing pro promoters won't let the fight
show that we want to see put on yeah so
then somebody's going to step up i blame
it i'm covered
we was bored for a long time like we're
watching that damn thing yeah right yeah
oh
that wasn't come on he's never really
been a pressure fighter now okay okay i
don't study fights like you guys he
usually fires off the back foot he fires
that right hand off he's not going
like he's not going in at all oh he's
easy
all right
jake looks huge
looks pretty much bigger
tyler's got samoan legs
oh
he's got he borrowed mark hunt's legs
[ __ ] fight man short shorts yeah it's
like no media it's just logan down there
dude the camera down
right now you got to take a polaroid
look at that
oh
oh that was a damn
come on logan down there talking [ __ ] to
he would right now as we're fighting
yeah of course is he yeah
if a t would just do the right hand and
logan starts laughing t
t wood looks just as fast and crisp
though yeah he looks good watch out
he looks good
doubled up on that jab maybe that three
minutes
yeah three minute rounds is it two or
three i think there's three two i think
they're threes i know i know jake wanted
three minutes because he thought he
could drag with the aspirin was two
minutes so i'm not sure if it's the same
it's eight rounds right this is three
minutes no we're not sure
we'll see i think it's three i think
it's three minutes eight rounds and for
some reason there was talk about there's
no drug testing i don't know what the
[ __ ] that meant but there was a whole
other night wait there's no drug testing
no no no
yeah i think i i don't think fighters
should be able to take not only
something no it's super dangerous no
yeah nobody touched them pride but
anyways so
i don't know
probably yeah yeah vanderbilt was on
anyway so everybody was on the process
for me yeah damn yep almost everybody
was everywhere you think fedor was on do
you think fedor was on it i don't think
fedor was on yeah russian oh yeah i
don't think so yeah because russians
don't they don't they never do anything
never never turns out but i don't think
fedor
you know you know the russians were
kicked out of the olympics
rules means that's the first line they
tell you we do not test fire yes
[Music]
is this going to go to the [ __ ]
decision i'm going to be pissed it feels
like it's going to the decision well
yeah well at least not one i mean
they're both but they're feeling each
other out that's what they're doing yeah
the real boxing match are feeling each
other out now if they keep filling each
other out for [ __ ] we get in the
fourth then we're in trouble
what the [ __ ] he's like haunting him
damn because in order for willie get
knocked out he's gonna have to take a
chance because if he keeps fighting like
this going his conversations
yeah
he's definitely gonna lose in decision
like unless it's like something yeah
you're you're an officer he's catching
elbow and glove though you're in
cleveland ohio that's where he's from
yeah you ain't winning that decision
yeah
yeah you know i'm just saying based on
the [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean they're
gonna want to win jay paul looks good
man he still looks good dude if we're
only having those shitty fights yeah
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] he's going to fight
for about three years he got robbed
right there got rocked
i don't like his technique i don't like
jake paul's technique that much
well he's
woodley's being super timid maybe he's
just sitting trying to drag him out and
open it mike i like jake's movement
though he's
keeping that jab in his mess
he's got he's got long
arms
yep both both are super timid to throw
something brandon you don't miss this
[ __ ] at all not at all
no yeah why are you retiring so young
[ __ ] man stand up oh
i don't miss this
stand up like [ __ ] i've noticed that i
have no desire to do this [ __ ] ever no
zero none someone's like oh
now all this is gonna do a rampage
you know what
you fight shannon maybe yeah i don't i
don't want to i don't want to miss it i
don't want to miss it because so many
fighters kind of done it all dude they
retire
dude who got rocked
he's catching elbow and gloves but but
jake is being more aggressive like jake
is actually doing well which is freaking
crazy jake's gonna have to open up
though chin did you do you think he
wouldn't do well
i'm shocked i am
because tyron's and that's fair because
we don't know much about jake
you've only seen two right hands out of
them yeah he's a real fighter yeah but
when you start getting into like man
when you start meeting like
conversations with people that have
trained with them yeah that have worked
for them
i get it it's fight camp stuff and i
understand that but
it's still shocking though yeah it is
man
like multi-time
just keeping it shocking i mean it's
boxing though
it just goes to show that anyone can
come up with chin though it's crazy
oh yeah
i love it boxy
he's not way bigger tyron's [ __ ] he's
thick tyron's like muscular but yeah
jake is just bigger
you give that round
longer yeah
losing it down the car aggression
damn
i just want to see someone get knocked
the [ __ ] out man i'll be honest yeah we
all do what was the bet when you put it
on with t-wood what plus what just has
to win uh level plus one let me see 180.
earlier today it was 160. yeah let me
see julian to leon love that's an
interesting name
bj flores is the main coach i think
that's him right there right dj the leon
uh straight bet uh plus 170.
[Music]
yeah plus 170 is the best line i got
what do you think he's saying to him
right now
uh throw a punch dude yeah get active
yeah yeah yeah let's try and hit him
who is his coach right there who's that
guy
no idea i don't know man
i mean if i'm t-wood i'm hiring the best
[ __ ] he has good coaches yeah all right
yeah
oh you want to give woodley flat advice
no no wait a minute no don't please tell
what you're saying i want i want the
best coach
boxing coach
oh that's true but that's not boxing
though is it now
oh that kind of caught him there
see if i'm woodley here i'm hey yes
hang on him and just body shot hang on
body shot
come on now let's get into this
oh nice jab to the body there thank you
there's a parry
damn yeah i would make it a little
uglier if i'm woodley i'd make that
skinny steve harvey break it up dude
bulldog
that time i put his ass in the corner
yeah i do i might get ugly i wouldn't
sit back here like he's doing nice timid
timid nice and nice
oh he rocked them
though yeah it is yeah well these smart
strategies right to the bottom patient
same as that combo no mystery boy
woodley head that was a crisp you think
you think woody knows that
dude they both look good it's freaking a
trip
yeah they are yeah they do damn
by this fourth fifth round somebody get
them dropped yeah i think so yeah
i think four
oh [ __ ]
i think fifth round is done i'm calling
fifth round
yeah fifth or sixth by the way jake
hanging just at the edge of the pocket
like that
that's good man
you think boom boom's like hating in the
back of his head right now because
jake's making more money this everything
he ever made
you know he got hit if he shakes his
head that was nice
jake paul with a big flurry right there
that was a nice long uppercut damn
that's these paul bros can fight a
little can't they just kind of throw man
come on wood throw he ducked his head
what has to open up yeah he's just got
to throw he has to risk it
looking very good man
how much time he's going to figure out
that fan cuts off the clock for me
but then i'd rather also have the fans
damn that's that catch good this is
actually really good this is good
yeah now did kyle pass away getting the
food or
yeah
that's going to be some good people like
one minute up the street
tyrone chase him man
oh that one rocked him that one rocked
him rock jake yep oh [ __ ] i missed it
that one wrong
yeah that was right
that's why i started talking yeah that's
why he started talking yeah okay you hit
right at the bell whenever they
or talk or talk right oh yeah yeah that
usually means it hurt uh oh
oh oh so i yo
so show that replay
oh julia rose is there who's that chick
that's julia rose right
that's jake's fiance yeah that's funny
she's so much she's rather pretty wow
yeah i know you got some stuff yeah i
can't see it
here's the replay he missed though
bradley sorry
yep
nope
that didn't land that hit
did this
no no slipped them all
look at that technique
but here right here at the very end
right here at the very last watch right
here
right there throw some ice on the floor
let you let your hand let your guy get
another third another 10 seconds with
jake paul yeah there's no doubt i mean
we're just going to throw man
come on wood fourth or fifth oh yeah
loose now
oh this is amazing this is good this
watch i'm enjoying this [ __ ] now
come on t would you just stop it
i think they're gonna throw some nice
[ __ ] right here throw baby throw if
t-wood throws man he i think he'll get
it he can get him out of here they're
throwing right here you just gotta throw
he just has to open up yeah they're
throwing more action he's so timid come
on t
what is he trying to like get decision
why are you he's trying to bait him in
yeah
no
oh yeah that was a power shot yeah
he hit his elbow yeah
yeah damn
little faints i'll tell you what we
don't want to have happen this goes to
the seven and they're both really tired
that's good they don't look too tired oh
they look good looks good they look good
right now
are there three minutes right yeah three
minutes i said earlier man i i didn't oh
yeah i didn't i didn't think combos he
bailed on it i didn't think t was going
to look this good in going into the
photo you were super hated yeah by the
way whoa whoa whoa whoa
pretty much
wow
oh
and he's never been hit before nope not
like that he's not like that he's
actually oh he's [ __ ] oh he's done
he's not look at his legs he's done 100
he's done yeah i don't know oh no what
do you mean you know
he's not he's just chilling right now
one more time just relax
relax hold the right hand woodley left
hook right hand come oh come on
right there he got hit willa got hurt
come on woodley nice little oh my god
look at chappelle on the back yo this is
[ __ ] lit i can't tell you what t
woodley he's a champion guys don't [ __ ]
around you guys keep [ __ ] talking
about jake paul i've been telling you
from david
don't load up just throw just throw oh
my god
hey by the way hey by the way props to
jake paul got [ __ ] rocked and smiled
so you guys [ __ ] are [ __ ] on jake
paul he's tired no you're flip-flopping
jake's in trouble man yeah thanks jake's
in trouble yeah watch it is this this
big hit yeah yeah
watch boom
oh [ __ ] snag right on the nose got him
in the nose didn't knock him i rocked
him that wasn't done
that was in the front of the face that
was nice this is the bad one here that
was in the front this is the bad one
here the right hand right right here
boom yeah definitely behind me right
behind the air yep
all right that one rocked he
he uh
which is good
good defense that one i don't know or is
it this one let's see
oh yeah that one that one that was sure
yeah that's the my god through the ropes
yeah his eyes are all [ __ ] up but you
know what oh
that would
third round's close okay it's true you
could be through one but yeah i think
i'll go two two paul is on his toes and
he's a real oh oh
yeah dude he's answering back oh
nice
big upper dude
you know what he's playing with the big
boys brandon i've always left
if you want to [ __ ] with the big boys
you're going to get caught this guy's
the king flipper is so relaxed right now
why didn't he [ __ ] fight like this i
know oh [ __ ]
yeah that's true that's like jake paul
that's true colby covington dude this is
actually a good fight he has a good
fight he's a good fighter
and look look at t wood this is actually
really important
on the side man he's not a social media
guy don't [ __ ] around 3-1 or two two
yeah
that third round was the third round was
close it was close yeah you can give it
to him
jake had more output but he would land a
little harder take over though
no doubt he's taking over
yeah he's he's they just need to put
combos together might quit trying to
land one big one
oh i don't know it's gonna be working on
him really gonna have to drop him for
him to win everything correct yeah
exactly you gotta make him hit the mat
at least once
you are correct
yeah
you know what jake's a little timid
right now and he's breathing heavy he
needs to be tiber got power still and
no no
oh
you can still crack
i don't think
how much damage you think the body shots
are doing it to woodley right nothing
nothing right not much this guy's
[ __ ] i feel like a good one it's it's
bro that guy got abs on abs i think
what about the straight body shots like
that they don't really do much do it
careful with that right there that
little oh that was a good hit oh look
what at least
[Music]
though no matter what happens jake is
the real [ __ ] yes yes he is the real
deal yes he is he's tough as [ __ ] yeah
he's not denying that big shot yeah
i like it
yeah me too he's a legit dude in general
i mean
i mean come on you know he's like yeah
have you ever talked to him i just gotta
throw more no i like him though have you
ever had a conversation no i never oh
just kind of just shut up bradley i
don't know if you've ever met hey
bradley it's not [ __ ] on brian it's just
by commander not sherlock ryan
sorry i just want to make sure it caught
him oh i met him one time come on oh
there's another one which one i meant
probably i mean jakes will put out more
at a
nascar event okay
this one on our entire entertainment
party yo this is this is actually really
entertaining i'm loving this [ __ ] you
can tell because we're kind of quiet
it's funny yeah and we're like
he was a way better boxer
i gave him
and shame on me for oh you thought you
were a better boxer woodley no i never
said that oh you wouldn't
brandon don't say dumb [ __ ] all right
woodley oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
no just [ __ ] yeah
that was that one's tough this is tough
you say no i wouldn't give it to woodley
i'll give it to you so two three based
off firehoods yeah close yeah he caught
him but that's going jake's kind of
tailoring off a little bit you have you
have woodley right now no i have him
down two three okay he's won the last
two okay i got him that's not right now
i would have woodley up three too if i
was judging but yeah according to
farhood who does the
non-official scoring for showtime he has
him down where do you see that he showed
at the bottom got a while ago
maybe
are you sure
you know what's going to suck is if jake
paul does get knocked out and you have
those electric things on your shorts
yeah you'll see it i think he has it for
the way this fight's going to the
rematch not mad at no me neither mm-hmm
yeah i'll definitely watch it again same
time same batch yeah nobody's
embarrassed no no this is great [ __ ] no
[ __ ] 10 rounds though
dude you guys count
i think he's a little off dude
i mean remember he's not the official
judge
yeah caught him in the ground yeah
that's a nice shot they want you to they
want this direction if it's going there
okay t come on
i don't like this because then come back
you're down on the card i don't know how
you give jake that last round oh
why are you grabbing them though
well coming in listen
remember what i said when this [ __ ]
started
what did you say
oh it's fake yeah man
yeah this is not fake dude they are
swinging for the fence but at the end
though oh if he goes to the judges he
goes to judges
all day yeah boxing corrupt as [ __ ] yeah
yeah
so that's what i'm saying
of course right yeah all right all right
come on wood throw yeah oh jake open it
up
yeah a lot of white people though yeah
he's tired
we're real tired right now
so does he does do you think he knows he
has to knock him out though no no
because in my eyes i mean he's he's
winning this round tyron is
paying how far hood scored it like he's
gotta throw him see he's not cutting him
off he's following him a little bit too
much well because because jake paul jake
paul's throwing more
so that's probably why he's giving him
ground throw together just kind of throw
man and also cut him off if he throws
he's going to win this fight someone's
getting a little tired though yeah talk
about jake both both
would slow down
they've definitely come on
well it's nice to take a
round off
don't get enough rounds to take one out
yeah that's only eight rounds oh oh
how about oh
that's grazing on top of the head too
come on
tyrone just keeps coming forward man
[Music]
damn it yeah but he has to throw
something come on
man he was talking about your mama i
know get in there man
get fired up man
oh that was a nice joke lots of this
[ __ ] now yeah i know they're both
jake's breathing hard
you think he doesn't see that though six
rounds
oh oh oh i feel like if woodley would
put the pressure come on he could really
you could i do too
that round yeah
um i think he was a role model
he didn't throw much
yeah that's what the judge is more than
jake though jake
the body a couple times
yeah
you got he is he is kind of he does have
ring control he is pushing the fight
right like if you're going to score that
like who like let's say the strike goes
even you gotta go to ring control right
yeah
damn
all right does online have jake winning
or what they say
ah chad what do you guys think who do
you guys have winning
spam it in the [ __ ] chat way off
let's go what do you guys think farhood
off am i off spamming spamming talk to
us
whose phone i don't know but i think
yeah
okay
that's the previous guy right now
now did he make the pizza himself or
where do you go a lot of people are
saying jake domino's we also ordered
postmates a lot of people are saying
jake's up a lot of people are saying
woodley though too it looks like i think
woodley's up one round
that's how i have a score all right i
think he's tied three three two like
these the next two rounds three three
right now three three or it's three
three or four two for jake
yeah three three or four two for jake
okay let them apart damn it
come on man i think three three is the
safest call to make
here we go here we go
so it's 3-3
wow
damn he gave [ __ ] paul that last
round
remember man he's just throwing more
yeah he's throwing more you're telling
me woodley's won one [ __ ] round
you're out of your mind
no disrespect steve
see see
his corner probably telling him that
he's winning so he's no he can't be
doing that
you know what do you think that's what
i'm saying do you think he knows that he
needs to knock him out no because he's
he's uh yeah i see him big big john big
john just said it's 5-1 jake
yeah so he has it 5-1 for jake because
well he's just too square and he's not
throwing enough i think i think it's
four two oh nice and nice that's a nice
cookie that's he just said the same
thing he's like willie's just not
throwing enough if he had more output
he'd be one in the fight i ain't gonna
argue with big john
why is he if big john says five one it's
[ __ ] probably five one yeah so we're
up i'm off five one yep
i feel like this is it then yeah woodley
needs a knockout calm down buddy
that's it
you got one more round yeah and you got
10 grand on this fight though
11.
11. you know counting the ground to him
you got to count that yeah see that's
how i feel when someone says they spent
money
oh
damn
yeah i'm more he's just not throwing
punches answered a lot of [ __ ]
questions
get hit yeah stay in the fight stay
focused it looks good answers more
questions about jake than woodland he
looks good
and he's got endurance by the way so
jake jacob he's dead
that tommy fairies i think so yeah 100
he's beating that kid
yeah man be a good next step for him too
yeah i mean
he's granted guys with no wins but he's
i feel like he's gonna steamroll that
kid
he would probably knock him out yeah
come on tyler get to get this get this w
man
jacob's tired though look he looks tired
but he's still fighting
tyra might be tired too though man the
bummer is in woodley's corner then he'd
be like dude you're down [ __ ] six
rounds bud you gotta we gotta go balls
to the walls here especially you want
that rematch well he's following him but
he's just you know he's just not he's
just not throwing you know that's what
i'm listening
yeah oh [ __ ] well he landed
that was nice he caught him he caught
woodley with that i think he caught
woodley i'm convinced that they just
want the rematch
there's no rematch so yeah right yeah
it's only if woodley wins if jake wins
he moves on
he's doing great
he's doing great that's what that's why
it's you know if woodley wins you
automatic rematch if he wins there's no
rematch
hey what'd you think of dana's comments
about the jake paul thing which comments
oh he said he said uh because they jake
said he's a flash in the pan no jake no
jake said that he's like he's like if i
ever run into
dana knock him out knock him out which
he would you probably probably what dana
said i said well that's about par for
what he would suggest he's like get in
line there's a bunch of people that want
to knock me out and he also said like he
goes it seems like he seems like along
lines because you fight people who are
older than you and like that's hilarious
yeah he's going pretty funny
yeah he goes he goes uh he's like yeah
it seems like kind of in line with what
he's doing he's like i'm 52. he's like
i'm 52 he seems like he'd want to fight
me that's what he's doing he's fighting
[ __ ] 50 year olds
one 1-0 dana
who slipped and landed
no that's a great shot man he's he won
this fight
he won this fight how insane is this
let's see what happens come on yeah
he has to know he's down this round
yeah man one more round
come on
man jake when you open up jake and jake
can weather your storm and catch you he
just starts throwing back fists there
guys there he goes there goes oh come on
come on come on would you throw i think
my thing is what does jake do so he
fights tommy and then is it then where
do we go fight some real guys his
brother he's gonna keep trying to talk
[ __ ] to connor he wants to fight connor
dana well
the only way that can happen if dana
allows him to fight that ain't gonna
happen
dude connor's small dude i mean that's
like i said connor's 170 when just
walking around maybe like maybe one he's
a lot smaller maybe 180 closer i know
who the data might let him fight is one
of the diaz bros yeah yeah that'd be fun
i think he'd let him fight nick he'd let
him find nick no he's gonna fight nick
not they still have some same years left
they're not gonna let him yeah and not
know they're not gonna risk
they would let him take that fight yep
but they'd want to be cut in on the
promotions yes right yeah
what's that do for jake though if he
fights nick diaz and knox
yes nick diaz hasn't fought ain't beaten
i'm sorry but he didn't think he i don't
know that's why this is how diaz is is
in the mind of a lot of jake paul's
audience it's the only thing but that's
the kind of the point right
now no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no but
here chias is a
ufc hall of famer yeah
he's a huge name one of my favorite
brings nick brings the audience that
will sell so much more
it's yeah
compared to woodley not even close
way more nick hasn't fought or in five
years and he's fighting [ __ ] robbie
long it's been a huge dude i mean also
jake paul fought ben askren
we're talking about people that are in
line with his family like he's going to
fight anyone he thinks he could be i
can't well he's going to get the
crossover because his fans going to
watch him fight a turkey so he can fight
anybody he fights and you get the diaz
crowd of course huge massive
now does he beat nick no
[Music]
nick can [ __ ] box man yeah and that's
that's the one there's a box box the
amount of output look how tired jake is
now nick is going to push him to the
brink of just [ __ ] just quit all
eight rounds
all the way around
it's just going to be like around here
he'll be talking about this last round
timer's just got letting go
man you've got anything in yourself
you're losing these five seconds oh my
god dude he's always winning this fight
he's going to win the fight that's
what's insane dude
i get what good for him you know good
for him
jake paul obviously tired oh [ __ ] big
right hand break him he's not hitting
him throw him off man
you're both trying to hold
oh he's in trouble
he's in trouble get him man get him in
seconds throw i don't think he's not
gonna throw a punch
yeah yeah right
that's why he thinks he won yeah i know
man
that woodley's gonna get on the mic like
that was rod blah blah blah but it
doesn't matter no
like if your corner man ain't telling
you you think you're winning too because
he's hurting him yep so big johnny said
six two paul yeah yeah
yeah that's fine that makes sense yep
that's fair
you know i would love to hear what jake
says on the mic look at his mom i bet
you jake's pretty humble on the mic he's
gonna call somebody out but i bet he's
pretty humble yeah y'all turn the
subtitles on
oh that's not that's not something yeah
i want to hear this so bad i do too
tyler
you have headphones over there tom
really did well though you know hey
bradley you were right man that
sometimes was fast
you're so damn fast
like everything of all that like what
what yeah yes anything but yes it
ashamed of it yeah it looks like it's
jake you gotta be one of those fast
readers regardless of the outcome from
here oh la we look it's just you can't
even do this holy [ __ ]
jake definitely outworked him look at
that that is so [ __ ] crazy you gotta
especially the jabs
the length the length
damn
that was great
that's a good fight it was a way better
fight than i thought it would be yeah
better than i thought that's way better
for sure
yeah and jake paul showed you know what
he did
he came to fight he was in shape he did
it's not like jake beats them just
[ __ ]
jay paul fought a real guy he's
impressive yeah got the main thing is he
got rocks where do you go from here if
you're if you're jake's manager what do
you do i don't i don't give them to a a
really good no
i don't do the diaz fights no i would do
tommy fear if you want yeah tommy
tommy'd be good tommy fury but he would
like tommy fury up i think so um but i
think he's very serious so he's going to
want to push himself the nick diaz thing
i don't you know i mean not just
nick has to fight robbie but you know
um uh diaz ain't the way to go if you're
trying to get a win
nick diaz is not a good idea
no has nicky has been training this
whole time he is all in these oh nick
he's doing triathlons
yeah have you not seen him like how old
is nick probably about two or three
years ago he's 38.
he hasn't fought in five years that's
how long it'd be a good time to get it i
think it's a good fight he's always
trying to
if you have to pick the two i guess you
go with nick if you want to save an
easier fight but nate wouldn't mop the
floor with them i think
it's just a bad idea with this their
cardio their chins their boxing style
yeah it's a bad idea
so i wouldn't do that
um they're not gonna do dylan dana's
cause they've done that basically that's
good
you gotta you gotta have a real fighter
you gotta have a real boxer if you're
gonna step in there well you gotta you
gotta have you gotta know how to box bro
who do you think it is
i'm loading up too much i wanna see him
fight a real boxer man it depends what
he wants to do if he wants to keep going
it's like you look at this i like this
though
78 74. i like this i like the score 78
74. yeah it depends what do you want for
taking that i appreciate it
if you want to fight for the next five
years then you do the next step but if
you just want to continue get paid you
fight your brother there you go but i
want i don't i want to see jake paul
fight who i want to see the what level
you want to see this is a pretty good
level man fight some amazing boxers what
level you want to see him get to you
know what's happening
at his age like
he's not going to fight canelo no no
he's not what about miles what's up huh
they were talking [ __ ] this is a good
decision
what decision that i'm actually very
excited
i'm actually that's a split decision are
you hearing this 77.75
what
77-75 775
for woodland you know what if they're
smart they give it to woodley and we
have the rematch correct yes
let everybody get paid let everybody
make crazy 7874 you'd have to join oh
yeah that's right yep
he deserves it that's fair
the kid deserves it should have been a
split but yeah but it was insane so
insane i can't believe it i think he's
good for fighting and i think he's good
it was it was a good fight here's my
question it was a good fight yeah both
of you guys yeah everybody here where's
his ceiling at like how far is he going
to go do you just fight like these old
and i'm not saying woodley's washed up
that's updated i think it's up to you is
that the like that's the the i tell you
i'll tell you what the ceiling is i'd
love to see him julio caesar chavez jr
is his is
his ceiling
that level julio cesar chavez jr the one
wait they're trying to make money fights
though but i'm saying oh he's saying
what the ceiling is yeah i'm saying like
i'm saying like in a year like two years
two three years i'd say that's like how
does he do it again
that's a monster i would love to see
that uh mozzarella slows down so mozart
slows down he's got the power he's got
the boxing boxing terrible matchup yeah
he's amazing he's a bad matchup he's
but all doesn't he's also a very
slow-paced fight
so he'll he'll pick him apart
yeah i think i keep playing his game to
make the most amount of money
until he loses someone that is like i'm
losing the conversation everyone's gonna
go like logan oh of course you lost
conor mcgregor yeah but it's the biggest
fight ever ah and connor is a much
better boxer but connor is smaller i
don't know this one i'm saying i'm but
i'm saying i think that's
like that's like
he wasn't big in boxing anyways he was
good it was decent but yeah
right dad yeah he never like beat
anybody like here i mean hello he lost
answer in silva what about anderson
silva
why why no no
i like that i like that i like this why
not oscar de la hoya
oscar's fighting v-tour next bigger guy
that's where he gets too much of a [ __ ]
he wants to because they want the
popular officer's gonna lose the vitor i
think he's i think i think so too i
think i think ashton still was the best
knight who's he calling it who's he
calling out he's just saying that's good
okay well let us know because he's gonna
say
something he's gonna say conor mcgregor
you're not gonna say tommy conor
mcgregor torment fairy conor mcgregor
he's gonna call it connor because that's
almost 100 it's not going to happen yeah
you're right that's connor got a broken
foot i'm calling it right now it doesn't
matter let him call him out after this
huge win is going to go viral so much
traffic yes that's all he cares even
though he's not going to get the fight
all he wants is the traffic conor
mcgregor guarantees but his ankle is
hanging out so it doesn't matter i think
dylan he's not going to call out dylan
danis no way no
does not have enough clout for this guy
no he's calling out conor
mcgregor i wish he called my fat ass out
you'd kill that guy man yeah see i'll
respect the tower he's a hall of famer
yeah bit of a good fight he's class act
man i love this kid i love him
yeah come on man he's a [ __ ] he put
he steps in there and [ __ ] does some
[ __ ]
this coach on the right's eyeballs are
popping out huh
he's good people man his coach on the
right like he do a lot of drugs i mean
his coach on the right has checked his
blood pressure
is he going to say let's be honest
that's [ __ ] although he gave him one
it's especially my hometown where's that
at
where's that one judge at come on
yeah i went one shot the whole fight
that one judge probably wasn't around
when the internet started yeah he's
right he's right i mean he he's dude
we're looking looking all good we've
still got the victory okay come on man
yeah wait for the conor mcgregor
call-out to be fighting for barely three
years and be able to be
unbelievable it's nuts unbelievable oh
boxing though different game man
you talking [ __ ] about tommy fury right
now i knew it oh the first ic you see
tom fury 7-0 he goes four rounds i think
he knows no he's making sense he's like
fear has been fighting he has seven
fights he fought a four-round [ __ ]
fight look at me i think he knocks fury
how's that pizza
we have a bunch of pizza did you just
get it from italy yeah no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no don't
bring it done we don't
yeah i like jorge oh look you have
called out names he said
india's
hey mozzarella there you go no no no no
no he said he's three nights we'll see
i've been in a box for 18 months i've
been a been to
cut my hair uh brushed my teeth my nose
is crooked
the past he's a tough [ __ ] kid to
this i might need to chill
out and wait for conor mcgregor i made
that up but uh yeah yeah that's what
he's doing
you know you got to ask yourself for
real like okay so you want to get really
good at boxing is it worth the brain
damage that this is that when you're
this age you're making mistakes you're
fighting good guys no no for him is it
worth the money 15 million
it's worth it
for 18 man hold on i wouldn't i don't
think he got much breaker bro we've
we've traded it for way less than that
what i'm saying much brain damage to mma
no you don't you don't get it though
boxing might be a little different
because with boxing if he wants to get
really good and go the next level with
moz vidal and guys like that he's gonna
have to train his ass off he's gonna be
getting hit by really good guys is it
worth being dizzy losing your memory and
why do you say there's less brain damage
in mma than there's more grappling
wrestling
jobs
so when we train also there's a lot more
wrestling so i take things to the ground
right i'm not just constantly getting
different a whole different approach
yeah you know mma once you get dropped
real bad the fight's over you're gonna
stop there
stand up you've got an eight count
there's trauma they put you back out
there you're not getting another got it
got it got it and it's just the jazz
yeah over and over and when you get
dropped like that you you're that's that
means you're concussed yeah right that's
all it is that's what it means yeah
uh i mean he's crying huh um he's just
from here yeah talking about your little
brother dude yeah honestly i i it's like
you can't even hit on jake paul at this
point no at all
[Music]
but they're awesome